tout de suite notre second débat débat
de société vous le savez on choisit le
plus souvent décalé de l'actualité du
jour avec cette question comment
protéger nos enfants des contenus
pornographiques la secrétaire d'État
envisage de conditionner l'accès au site
porno à la détention d'une carte
bancaire comment pourrait fonctionner un
tel filtre explication réaction avec
Fabien avec elle
[Musique]
à 28 ans Clémence avatier fait partie
d'une génération qui a grandi avec le
port no sur Internet accessible partout
et tout le temps dans les années 2000 il
y a l'apparition des tubes un peu comme
youtube mais dédié à la pornographie et
du coup nous on s'est pris ça de plein
fouet on a grandi avec et qu'on était
qu'on a passé 22 23 ans on s'est dit bah
c'est pas fantastique d'avoir grandi
avec ça aujourd'hui Clément veut mettre
en garde les plus jeunes face aux
dangers du porno il a rejoint
l'association we are lovers dont les
bénévoles interviennent chaque mois dans
des collèges et lycées où il rencontre
souvent des ados en détresse il y a des
souffrances elle s'exprime de façon
multiple certaines ça va être dans
l'intimité parce que ils avaient pas
envie d'être confrontés à ces images
pour beaucoup d'entre eux c'est
involontaire à une question qui vient
vraiment à chaque fois c'est pourquoi
les adultes nous permettent d'avoir
accès à des sites pornographiques
pourquoi vous nous expliquez que c'est
interdit par la loi et pourtant on y a
très facilement accès depuis 2020 la loi
oblige en théorie les sites pornos à
barrer l'accès au moins de 18 ans mais
en réalité un simple clic permet à
quiconque de contourner une déclaration
de majorité dans un récent rapport la
délégation au droit des femmes du Sénat
appelle à enfin faire appliquer la loi
la secrétaire des tâches chargée de
l'enfance assure que le gouvernement a
pris la mesure de la situation on parle
aujourd'hui de millions de mineurs qui
ont chaque mois sur des sites
pornographiques avec un tiers de
séminaire qui a moins de 15 ans et le
premier âge de vue du pornographique
environ 11 ans donc ça c'est quand même
des chiffres qui doivent nous
interpeller aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
dispositif efficace on a évoqué le sujet
de la carte bleue comme un dispositif
possible pour déjà bien filtrer
soumettre l'accès au site porno à une
empreinte de carte bleue la solution ne
serait pas parfaite de la vue même de la
ministre puisque des ados peuvent
posséder une carte bancaire
que l'usage d'un VPN synonyme d'une
connexion depuis l'étranger permettrait
de contourner le dispositif mais la
démarche aurait le mérite de protéger au
moins les plus jeunes et surtout d'être
apportée demain la CNIL protectrice de
nos données personnelles y est même
favorable sous certaines conditions ça
peut être mis en place techniquement
très vite parce que l'avantage de cette
solution si elle n'est pas parfaite elle
s'appuie sur une infrastructure qui
existe déjà on fait déjà des paiements
par carte bleue il y a déjà des sites
qui font un paiement de 0 € ou qui
vérifie que vous avez une carte bleue
valide avant de vous de vous permettre
d'y accéder l'acné la mis quand même un
point de mise en garde une condition
très importante qui est qu'il faut qu'on
s'assure que cette vérification elle
soit bien faite par un tiers selon les
règles de l'art c'est à dire que ça ne
conduise pas à ce que vous donniez votre
numéro de carte bleue et notamment pas à
l'éditeur du site pornographique un
tiers qui pourrait être la CNIL
elle-même pendant ce temps comme
régulateur de l'audiovisuel est au prise
devant la justice avec les éditeurs de
sites pour adultes l'industrie du X
traîne des pieds pour protéger
effectivement les mineurs de ces
contenus pourtant le temps presse dans
son rapport le Sénat qualifie de viol
psychique l'exposition des enfants au
porno
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités dans dans ce débat Marie-Rose
Moreau bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
pédopsychiatre chef de service de la
maison de Solène et auteur de 50
questions sur les bébés les enfants et
les adolescents ou comment devenir des
parents ordinaires c'est publié aux
éditions pensez sauvages Justine Atlan
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directrice
de l'association de protection de
l'enfance sur Internet yen France
j'accue également Céline pig bonsoir et
à vous porte-parole d'oser le féminisme
et puis en duplex avec nous Benjamin
Bayard qui est le co-fondateur de la
Quadrature du Net bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue Mathieu croissanto et restez à
mes côtés évidemment première réaction
peut-être on va on va démarrer sur cette
mesure envisagée je le rappelle par le
gouvernement la carte bancaire comme
filtre à l'entrée à l'entrée d'un site
pornographique est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une bonne idée
alors en tous les cas il faut protéger
nos enfants
de ces contenus de ce c'est le vieux la
notion de viol psychique et juste c'est
à dire que les fractions la frayeur les
effets sur des enfants en développement
sont extrêmement importants et plus ils
sont petits plus c'est grave plus ils
sont plus enfin plus ils sont exposés
plus c'est grave donc il y a et à tous
les âges les effets sont un peu
différents mais même chez un adolescent
l'exposition à la pornographie
et donc il faut les protéger alors
quelle est la meilleure façon de les
protéger moi je le sais pas mais ce que
je sais c'est que les protégeons pas
assez comme société comme adulte comme
parent et que donc nous nous nous sommes
en train de fabriquer non seulement des
frayeurs des représentations fausses de
du corps de l'autre mais aussi des
blessures en fait parce que c'est
tellement profond et tellement
violent que ça s'inscrit dans le
développement même des enfants et des
adolescents Justine Atlan il y a une loi
qui a été votée il y a 2 ans avec un
amendement déposé par la sénatrice LR
mari Mercier censé justement déjà
interdire ces sites pornographiques aux
mineurs elle est pas si on en arrive à
dire il va falloir utiliser la carte
bancaire comme comme moyen d'accès en
quelque sorte ça veut dire qu'elle n'est
pas appliquée tout simplement cette loi
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas les
principaux concernés que sont les sites
pornographiques n'appliquent pas
effectivement le cadre réglementaire
dans lequel ils sont censés opérer leur
activité donc de ce fait ils sont dans
l'inégalité donc ils sont illégaux et
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
procédures en cours que l'art comme
amener mais nous aussi en France avec la
Voix De l'Enfant qui demande à la
justice tout simplement de constater que
ces sites graphique ne respecte pas la
loi et que donc à cet égard il faut les
bloquer c'est à dire que les fournis sur
l'accès à Internet les blocs pas parce
qu'ils se sont décidés de
pornographiques ce que les sites
pornographiques essayent de faire dire
tout simplement parce qu'il ne respecte
pas la loi donc la carte bleue fait
partie effectivement des outils qu'on
peut mettre en place c'est loin d'être
la seule il y a évidemment aussi la
carte d'identité qui est vraiment
effectivement peut être à côté très
intrusif mais c'est possible aussi dès
leur qu'on passe aussi par un tiers de
confiance c'est-à-dire quelqu'un de
tiers nécessite pornographique qui va
qui va valider le fait que vous avez
bien l'âge que vous avez ensuite tout
était écrasé tout était effacé et le
site pornographique s'ouvre à vous
finalement puisque vous avez montré pas
de Blanche c'est à dire votre majorité
il y a aussi des systèmes de biométrie
aujourd'hui qui permettent d'envoyer une
photo de se filmer ou un selfie et qui
vont évaluer en fonction de votre visage
globalement l'âge que vous avez il faut
savoir que c'est quand même très très
précis la marge d'erreur elle est de 2
ou 4% au pire alors beaucoup autour de
18 ans parce que c'est là où
effectivement c'est le plus dur de
repérer mais enfin c'est très très
faible donc aujourd'hui il y a des
plateformes qui ne sont pas
pornographiques mais comme Instagram par
exemple qui met en place différents
systèmes en même temps et en fait l'idée
c'est de se dire on va laisser au
consommateurs le choix on va lui
proposer à peu près trois quatre
systèmes qui existent et on va bien voir
finalement ce que le consommateur
supporte de faire et puis en font ça
sera certainement que la solution la
plus fluide la plus acceptable émergera
c'est une pique on oppose souvent dans
un dossier comme celui-là
protection de la vie privée puisque les
les propositions qui sont faites là oui
on peut considérer qu'elles sont
intrusives en matière de vie privée et
protection de l'enfance est-ce qu'il
faut dépasser ce débat pour je pense
qu'il faut dépasser ce débat parce qu'il
y a un principe aussi de
proportionnalité entre les deux entre
les deux principes que vous méditez là
effectivement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et ce qu'on est en capacité
de voir sur la question des sites
pornographiques et on a été nous
auditionné au rapport du Sénat pour
rappeler qu'un certain nombre
d'évidences aujourd'hui des articles de
recherche scientifiques mentionnent et
c'est écrit dans le rapport du Sénat que
90% des scènes de de des scènes
pornographiques qui sont présentées sur
les grandes plateformes contiennent des
scènes de violences sexuelles et font en
particulier puisqu'on parle des enfants
et il faut le lier font aussi l'apologie
la pédocrinalité par exemple une des
premières catégories sur pornhub puisque
c'est un des sites qui est bien sûr dans
une des procédures d'entrave à la loi
c'est la catégorie teen et la catégorie
il y a une autre catégorie qui moi
m'insurgent énormément qui s'appelle
fantasme familial et donc à l'heure où
en même temps on veut avoir la civile
qui avance sur cette question de la
pédocrinalité nous on a des retours de
terrain de des retours de terrain donc
effectivement il y a cette question de
l'effraction psychique de l'impact
psychique sur les enfants et puis aussi
sur la façon dont ces vidéos sont
utilisées sont mobilisés dans des dans
des viols dans des viols c'est c'est
quand on parlait d'exposition
involontaire aux enfants il faut penser
aussi aux enfants victimes d'inceste
victime de viol pédocriminels qui sont
qui sont confrontés à ces images pour
pouvoir être comment dire piéger dans un
dans un scénario enfin scénario c'est un
mauvais terme excusez-moi de viol donc
la question de la protection des enfants
devrait être un principe supérieur à la
question qui occupe tout le monde et en
particulier les sites qui veulent se
défendre qui est la question de la
confidentialité et donc là je j'aimerais
quand même dire que on a aussi quand
même des des petits comparaison européen
et je finirai là il y a aujourd'hui une
stratégie d'entrave d'entrave avec une
multiplication de recours de contentieux
il y a un recours au Conseil d'État il y
a une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité il y a des recours
dans tous les sens de la part de ces
sites de la part de ces sites parce
qu'il gagne du temps il gagne du temps
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait en
Angleterre en Angleterre il y a eu plus
de 11 procédures civiles en Angleterre
et au bout de trois ans en fait après
avoir dépensé des millions et des
millions en recours finalement le
processus s'est arrêté et on a toujours
pas de protection des mineurs donc il
faut être effectivement extrêmement
clair sur les millions qui sont
développés par ces plateformes pour
faire un travail à la loi et à
l'application de la loi Mathieu pardon
mais cet arbitrage entre les deux
principes il tient pas la route parce
que au cinéma s'il y a un film interdit
au moins de 16 ans ou interdit au moins
de 18 ans l'exploitant peut demander la
carte d'identité de de du spectateurs
qui se trouve que sur le numérique on
demande pas de carte d'identité mais
c'est l'argument c'est l'argument
déployé noter
je suis d'accord c'est un argument qui
ne tient pas pour l'alcool pour le tabac
quand vous allez dans un magasin pour
les jeux en ligne pour les casinos il y
a plein d'endroits où on contrôle l'âge
et ça c'est sur lequel ça ne pose aucun
problème et c'est vraiment le narratif
de l'industrie qu'il faut aujourd'hui
démontrer et que que ça suffit que ça
fait quand même deux ans aujourd'hui
qu'on attend l'application de la loi et
j'espère que la justice qui est saisie
par ces sites va enfin garder bon sens
pour l'instant il y a pas eu de sanction
il y a une concerta une procédure de
concertation de médiation pendant ces
termes de chercheurs régulateur quand
même leur com et ses sites avec CSA
qui a mis en demeure ces sites la
justice saisie et pour l'instant
effectivement une médiation prioritaire
de constitutionnalité je vais vous
redonner la parole dans un sens je vous
propose un témoignage on va s'appuyer
beaucoup sur les vous avez été
auditionnés les unes et autres mais on
va s'appuyer sur les auditions qui ont
été réalisées ici au Sénat et entendre
plusieurs témoignages dans ce débat
celui pour commencer de Sophie GL et les
maîtresses de conférence en sciences de
l'information et de la communication à
Paris 8 c'était le 30 mars son audition
et elle a mené une étude entre 2015 et
2017 auprès de 200 adolescents voilà ce
qu'elle dit
cette enquête nous a appris que la
rencontre avec les images sexuelles
étaient d'abord involontaires pour les
filles au moment du téléchargement
illégal ou de du streaming peu de filles
de cet âge nous ont confié consulter ce
type de site volontairement donc entre
15 et 17 ans ou seulement de façon très
exceptionnelle avec des copines de
nombreux garçons en revanche ont pu le
faire et ça c'est apparu comme une norme
il apparaissait que l'accès à ces images
pour peu qu'on sorte sur des sites
adultes étaient très faciles parmi les
mesures qui restreignent aujourd'hui un
accès à ces images les adolescents ont
pu évoquer des interdits familiaux des
interdits religieux mais jamais
d'impossibilité technique pour y accéder
alors on va on a commencé à donner
quelques chiffres mais ce rapport
sénatorial et l'audition de sofigel il
faisait partie de de des travaux
préparatoires à ce rapport on va avoir
les chiffres qui étaient publiés dans ce
rapport grâce à Quentin rebonsoir
Quentin calmé se rapporte je le cite un
consommation massive et ban chez les
enfants et les adolescents comme chez
les adultes voilà on va le remontrer ce
rapport qui est là effectivement qui a
été publié le 28 septembre dernier qui
est disponible sur le site du Sénat qui
est public et on le rappelle ce rapport
c'est la première fois qu'une instance
parlementaire et bien travailler
s'intéresser au phénomène du porno en
France et il a chiffré effectivement le
phénomène en reprenant un sondage
réalisé en 2018 par OpinionWay et on va
voir ces chiffres on compte 10% des
enfants de moins de 11 ans qui sont
exposés à des images pornographiques une
trentaine de % des enfants avant 13 ans
36% chez les garçons 26% chez les filles
vous le voyez les chiffres explosent
ensuite c'est 70% des garçons avant
l'âge de 15 ans 53% chez les filles
quasi tous les garçons avant 18 ans 95%,
86% des jeunes femmes tout cela alors
que la loi on le rappelle dispose
clairement qu'il est interdit de donner
à voir des images pornographiques et des
mineurs c'est même l'article 227-24 du
code pénal la loi a même été précisé en
2020 pour dire que les sites ne peuvent
plus se contenter du simple déclaratif
c'est lié à un amendement qui venait du
Sénat faisait par Marie Mercier a été
évoqué tout à l'heure voilà et du coup
le site va plus contenter de cette
simple question avez-vous plus de 18 ans
donc on le voit cette loi n'est toujours
pas appliquée deux ans après son
adoption dernier chiffre avancé par le
rapport sur les 19 millions de visiteurs
unique mensuels on compte 2,3 millions
de mineurs ce sont des chiffres qui
datent de 2021 toujours si tu es dans le
rapport et on voit un phénomène nouveau
c'était évoqué dans le reportage de
Fabien Ricard mais avec l'accès facilité
ces images en streaming si vous savez
sur ces sites en tube le nom de ces
sites comme pornhub ou youporn avec un
très grand nombre d'images accessibles
sur ces sites mais alors le rapport il
consacre aussi toute une partie sur de
nouvelles pratiques via les messageries
instantanées là aussi un phénomène en
force progression nous dit ce rapport
sénatorial voilà ça se sont les chiffres
majeurs et les quatre co-rapporteurs
expliquent que les effets délétères
souhaite consommation de d'image
pornographiques chez les mineurs voilà
ce rapport parle de contenu de plus en
plus violent et toxique pour les mineurs
comme pour les adultes mais ces contenus
pornographiques avec des images de plus
en plus extrêmes ont un impact sur la
construction des gènes c'est contenu
construisent je cite une érotisation de
la violence et lie plaisir et domination
avec cette étude effectivement sur 304
scène porno dans les meilleures ventes
d'un des sites et car recensé en 2010
que 90% des scènes pornographiques
contenaient de la violence vous évoquez
ce chiffre voilà c'est sûr effectivement
304 scènes porno qui sont étudiés et en
plus de créer donc une vision déformée
et violente de la sexualité des
chercheurs auditionnaient pas la mission
d'information explique que pour l'enfant
les images pornographiques constituent
des images traumatiques qui n'est pas
capable d'analyser merci beaucoup
Quentin calmé je reviens vers vous
évidemment Marie Rose pour vous vous
dialoguez vous vous aider des
adolescents vous dites souvent mes ados
d'ailleurs
comment il qu’est-ce qui vous disent de
ces de ces images pornos un est-ce que
ils en parlent facilement est-ce que
c'est parce que moi dans ma génération
c'était un tabou on n'avait pas dire que
on avait acheté une revue ou quoi que ce
soit est-ce qu'ils ont pas le facilement
et d'autres qu'est-ce qu'ils en disent
est-ce qu'ils font là un petit peu la
part des choses ou est-ce que c'est
aussi voilà la violence à laquelle ils
sont confrontés il ou elle elle a
forcément de l'impact sur eux alors les
garçons en parlent beaucoup plus
volontiers que les filles ça c'est clair
des c'est
les mais les garçons régulièrement
peuvent en parler
alors ce qui est
ce qu'ils disent toujours lorsqu'ils
nous en parle alors faut
préciser que même si vont
s'ils vont sur les sites s'ils disent
qu'ils ont plus de 18 ans
ce qu'il voit souvent ça leur fait du
mal et ils en ont conscience nous
lorsqu'ils nous en parle mais maison de
Solène on est des thérapeutes on était
soignants mais ils nous en parle très
régulièrement et les garçons encore une
fois je remets tout de suite sur les
filles et ils peuvent dire j'y vais ça
me fascine mais mais en même temps par
exemple parfois ils font des cauchemars
ou ils se demandent quand même si c'est
normal ce la question de la domination
est une question extrêmement je pense
très très importante et effectivement il
était dit cette question du lien entre
le plaisir et la domination c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'extrêmement
toxique d'extrêmement d'extrêmement
qui entraîne des effets presque de
distorsion de la relation
et donc il si il nous en parle souvent
c'est ils vont poser des questions et
ils vont dire aussi les effets où ils
vont raconter que quand ils étaient
petits et qu'ils ont vu ça oui c'est
vraiment ça je me suis demandé si
c'était normal etc ça c'est les garçons
je trouve que chez les filles elles en
parlent beaucoup moins
c'est sûr qu'elle sont exposées la même
façon en tous les cas de manière
importante c'est mais elles vont jamais
en parler spontanément ou très rarement
mais si on le cherche parce que elle
elle disent parfois des choses qui leur
ont fait du mal ou des difficultés
qu'elles peuvent avoir dans la relation
à l'autre et tout ça et si on cherche
cette exposition on la trouve souvent
juste pour rebondir sur la question de
toi ils se disent que c'est la vraie vie
où ils se disent c'est du cinéma
alors ils se disent pas c'est la il dise
pas c'est pas si c'est un il se disent
pas c'est la vraie vie un peu
distanciation quand même un peu de
distanciation un petit peu en tout cas
chez les filles c'est sûr mais chez les
garçons aussi mais il se demande si il y
a quand même une une question sur la
norme quand même est-ce que les garçons
en particulier avec cette attente cette
notion d'attente il faudrait être
violent pour être un garçon par exemple
ça c'est des questions qui qui peuvent
se poser donc c'est justement le
problème c'est que c'est si une pensée
que c'était vraiment autre chose et que
ça n'a pas de rapport du tout avec la
vraie vie ça allait protégerait un peu
mais c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
flou que ça et par exemple chez les
jeunes adolescents mineurs mais jeunes
adolescents qui sont en période de
construction identitaire où ils sont
confrontés à la relation avec les autres
et bien cette question de comment on est
finalement quelque chose de l'ordre si
on le dit de manière un peu désuète
publications sentimentale commence on se
on se situe par rapport à l'autre pour
pour avoir des échanges pour échanger de
la tendresse pour échanger la sexualité
etc là cette question est vient viens
s'immiscer et elle vient introduire du
doute je pense et une confusion une
confusion Justine atelange reprend
certains des chiffres que Quentin
calmaient vient de nous donner et
notamment sur l'âge 10% des enfants de
moins 11 ans de moins de 11 ans exposé à
des images pornographiques la tendance
c'est quoi c'est de plus en plus tôt de
plus en plus jeune on voit vraiment
cette tendance se renforcer depuis
quelques années la tendance à aller vous
rajeunissement des usages numériques
parce que parce que les parents équipent
de plus en plus tôt leurs enfants sa
très honnêtement c'est le cas notamment
avec les tablettes qui donnent
l'impression aux parents que c'est pas
un téléphone c'est pas un smartphone
donc ça se donne plus facilement c'est
un écran dans lequel on peut avoir du
contenu en fait c'est juste un
smartphone géant donc on peut faire
exactement la même chose donc c'est vrai
que souvent les parents disent que vous
donneriez un smartphone à votre
ça fait 6 ans maintenant évidemment la
tablette c'est la même chose et la
tablette bah voilà donc effectivement
les enfants peuvent être confrontés tous
à la alors faut pas non plus tomber dans
le fantasme de les enfants tombent par
hasard dessus c'est pas vrai c'est peu
qui tombe par hasard dessus simplement
il faut pas minimiser la curiosité des
enfants la curiosité des enfants entre
eux dans une société
d'hypersexualisation de plus en plus
jeune ou effectivement les enfants à ce
qu'ils sont dans une société qui est
comme ça se posent des questions sans
doute un peu plus tôt qui ne le faisait
avant la période fameuse période de
latence elle finit par se rétrécir
beaucoup ce qui est notre sujet mais
voilà mais tout ça fait qu'effectivement
ils vont aller chercher des moteurs de
recherche où on cherche des mots et des
images arrivent puisque le mode image
est assez facile à trouver quand on sait
même quand on sait pas lire les vidéos
aussi enfin voilà donc effectivement
statistiquement c'est vrai qu'ils sont
de plus en plus jeunes exposés à ces
contenus et pour revenir à votre
question les sites pornographiques c'est
quand même essentiellement du streaming
et essentiellement des contenus qui se
montrent comme étant amateur c'est du
faux amateur mais ça se veut du amateur
donc ça laisse effectivement à penser
que ce qu'on voit est vrai beaucoup plus
qu'avant les films pornographiques qui
étaient vraiment construits comme de la
cinéma avec une construction
cinématographique qui laissait pas à
penser que c'était vrai là aujourd'hui
c'est des vidéos courtes qui laissent à
penser qu'on ça a été filmé à la dérobée
comme ce que veulent voir les enfants
ils adorent c'est à dire à travers le
trou de la serrure de la chambre des
adultes et c'est ça que le
pornographique monte la pornographie
montre aujourd'hui donc ça entretient ce
mythe pour eux de on va découvrir ce que
font les grands derrière la porte de la
chambre et donc et donc c'est vrai que
c'est ça aussi qui est malhonnête et
tout ça participe effectivement à leur
faire croire que ils vont apprendre la
sexualité comme ça bon Benjamin Bayard a
disparu dans la couverture du net voilà
évidemment un problème technique et puis
n'est jamais revenu c'est son choix mais
j'ai peut-être moi prendre parce qu'il
avait un point de vue à à nous donner
notamment sur la question de l'âge
je vais pas
me mettre à sa place mais est-ce que
effectivement on peut considérer que la
règle enfin où les règles de coercitive
qu'on imagine que vous avez listé tout à
l'heure et effectivement semble assez
facile d'utilisation techniquement on
les on les applique de la même façon à
un enfant de 10 12 ou un enfant de 17
ans et demi vous voyez ce que je veux
dire par rapport à vos enfants
Benjamin pas à vous
peut-être qu'il aurait pas dit ça
d'ailleurs je voudrais pas voilà il faut
passer une question il faut définir un
âge alors la loi aujourd'hui c'est 18
ans c'est la majorité la majorité voilà
mais donc c'est pas une question on ne
cherche pas à aller creuser plus loin
que savoir si le consommateur en
l'occurrence de pornographie est majeur
ou pas point finalement son âge on s'en
fiche on veut savoir si les majeur qu'il
est 17,14 13 août c'est pas le sujet
est-ce qu'il a 18 ans ou pas est-ce
qu'il est capable donc on va demander à
tous les adultes de prouver leur
majorité celui qui n'est pas capable de
prouver sa majorité alors par défaut
considère qu'il est mineur et donc on
l'empêche d'avoir accès c'est tout on
n'a pas besoin de savoir comment il
s'appelle quel est ce que j'ai bien
compris ça parce que c'est ça
alors je me fais encore une fois
l'Apocalypse on n'a pas la même sexe
sexualité 17 ans ou à 17 ans et demi que
à 14 ou 15 évidemment ou encore -12 quoi
de sexualité alors
premièrement il y a quand même un
constat qui est clair c'est que avant de
commencer à discuter de l'âge et du
seuil tel qu'il est dans la Loire
l'incompréhension que moi j'ai qui a été
rappelé c'est que la loi n'est pas
appliquée moi je le trouve ça quand même
assez particulier
il y a les outils pour empêcher les
sites de de toucher les mineurs et on
les utilise pas de nous avancer à chaque
fois des argumentaires alors la
protection des consommateurs parce que
le bon père de famille ne veut pas ça de
ne pas finalement être pris par sa
conjointe en particulier sur le fait
qu'il consomme de la pornographie
ensuite il y a est-ce que c'est 18 ans
c'est le bon mon truc mais c'est pas le
fond du problème le fond du problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a un interdit
et c'est interdit n'est pas respecté et
que la loi n'est pas respectée et qu'il
y a entrave à l'application de la loi
par la multiplication des recours moi je
voulais aussi répondre par rapport à la
question de la distance et de la
question cinéma distance etc je pense
que il y a quand même quelque chose qui
est extrêmement fort dans le rapport qui
rappelle quelque chose d'essentiel et
qui est pourtant une évidence c'est que
c'est saine ne sont pas simulés 90% des
scènes contiennent de la violence
sexuelle et c'est saine contrairement au
cinéma ne sont pas simulés avec un
risque de
normalisation de la de la violence dans
le rapport sexuel pour pour ces jeunes
téléspectateurs j'ai envie de retourner
un peu la question sur la question de la
distance c'est en fait si on avait une
mise à distance moi je comme peut-être
vous le savez dans osez le féminisme on
est dans le cadre d'un procès je suis
exposé aujourd'hui à des à beaucoup
d'images pornographiques extrêmement
violente bah je suis désolé de vous dire
mais moi j'ai pas de distance et j'ai
effectivement je vois des femmes qui
sont aujourd'hui violentées violées et
vraiment on est sur des des actes qui
s'appréhendent et c'est ça que nous dit
la justice dans le cadre des procès
comme des actes de torture et de
barbarie d'accord donc la question des
mineurs et la côte est question de la
protection des mineurs se pose dans un
cadre et dans un contexte aujourd'hui où
il y a une surenchère de violence qui
même pour des majeurs et pour moi
traumatique et pour moi je suis enfin
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans notre
association même même nous nous sommes
suivis aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
traumatique parce que nous sommes
exposés à des images que j'estime à des
images d'acte de torture on parlera
sûrement du procès avec des scènes de
bukake c'est de ça dont on parle donc en
fait vraiment ce débat sur 17 ou 18 ans
quand on voit ce dont on est en train de
parler et par rapport au retour qui sont
fait nous on fait des interventions au
milieu scolaires on a des retours
souvent de professeurs ou d'infirmières
scolaires et je me suis un très bien
d'avoir discuté avec une infirmière
scolaire qui avait retrouvé une enfant
de 6e de 11 ans qui avait exposé à ces
images et justement elle elle n'avait
pas voulu mettre cette distance là et
elle avait dit à l'infirmière mais
c'est vrai est-ce que ça c'est vrai
est-ce que cette femme cette vraie femme
subit réellement ces gifs ces
étouffements c'est c'est strangulation
et ces scénarios d'horreur elle voulait
savoir si c'était réel et en fait j'ai
envie de lui dire mais malheureusement
oui c'est réel et donc le mot cinéma et
le mot cinéma est dénoncé dans le
rapport et ça c'est extrêmement
important de le dire et je ne suis pas
sûr que l'objectif de la protection de
mineur soit de leur de leur mettre une
distance par rapport à ces images mais
au contraire de recréer de l'empathie de
l'empathie parce que ces images
infirmière scolaire dans un coin juste
une question j'imagine qu'on n'est pas
le seul pays à se poser la question
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres pays qui ont
résolu ce problème de des 18 ans la
majorité alors effectivement
l'Angleterre a tenté de le faire il y a
quelques années mais elle a trouvé une
solution en fait elle s'est rendu compte
que le tiers de confiance qu'elle avait
choisi était en réalité une filiale de
mangy qui est le gros propriétaire de
toutes les plateformes de
de pornographie donc ils sont arrêtés là
et voilà et ça n'avait poursuivi et
c'est vrai que non il n'y a rien que
pour l'instant qui est de la même façon
en réalité que le on en revient à notre
problème qui dépasse la pornographie
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est incapable
d'identifier un mineur sur Internet quel
que soit ses usages ni sur les réseaux
sociaux on est capable de le faire mais
de le mettre en place et que donc
effectivement la pornographie en est un
exemple créant mais ça ne concerne pas
en réalité que là pornographie c'est que
la virgule
ce dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
c'est à dire pour acheter de l'alcool
des cigarettes etc
on est quasiment on n'y arrive pas sur
en fait on ne peut rien mettre en place
ensuite derrière il y a plein de choses
qui existent en réalité pour protéger
les mineurs en ligne des fonctionnalités
du paramétrage de l'éducation de
l'information il y a plein de choses
sauf qu'on ne rencontre pas les mineurs
sur Internet puisque eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs c'est vrai ce cache ne disent
pas qu'ils sont mineurs personne n'est
capable de dire Messi ils sont mineurs
donc en fait on passe à côté les uns des
autres et on n'arrive pas à les
atteindre donc on a un exemple je vais
vous donner la parole dans un sens je
reste sur le cette question de de
violence de plus en plus présente
presque systématique puisque c'est 90%
le chiffre de condamné tout à l'heure et
son impact sur la sexualité des enfants
parce que c'est le cœur de notre débat
on a déjà fait un débat sur la violence
dans dans les films pornographiques donc
c'est comment protéger nos enfants
écouter donc cette infirmière infirmière
scolaire en Seine-Saint-Denis elle avait
été également auditionnée au Sénat
s'appelle Samia gounouri nous pouvons
observer lors de ses consultations
infirmières individuelles et ou de ses
actions de prévention collective que
certains enfants adolescents à un âge où
ils sont en pleine construction peuvent
présenter des symptomatologies variées
allant du traumatisme lié au fait que
ses enfants et jeunes ne s'attendaient
pas aux images vidéos visionnées du fait
qu'il ne soit non préparé
et qu'ils n'ont pas le recul suffisant
jusqu'à donc ça peut conduire jusqu'à
une chute des notes des difficultés de
concentration qui peuvent avoir un
impact fort sur leur scolarité
sur leur réussite scolaire
cela passe aussi parfois par du repli
sur soi de l'isolement des troubles du
sommeil de l'alimentation des
omnibulations avec des scènes qui
reviennent en flashback à tout moment de
la journée et très souvent un important
sentiment de culpabilité de honte et de
dégoût
Marie-Rose Moreau je voudrais rester sur
la la banalisation de la violence et
est-ce que vous avez des témoignages de
d'une forme de banalisation de la
violence dans la sexualité de certains
des ados français aujourd'hui
alors
les
effectivement c'est un des risques et
les jeunes les jeunes adultes ou les
adolescents qui peuvent en parler déjà
quand ils en parlent ils se posent la
question c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure également quand nous ils nous en
parle c'est qu'il y a déjà une question
qui est posée ce qui est ce qui est pas
toujours le cas et puis il faut prendre
en compte un autre élément dans la dans
la suite de ce qui vient d'être dit par
l'infirmière scolaire c'est
qu'effectivement ils peuvent être
traumatisés mais c'est pas si simple
c'est une fois qu'on est traumatisé on a
des flashbacks on a on a des frayeurs on
a des tas de troubles mais on a aussi
une sorte de compulsion à répéter le
traumatisme c'est-à-dire c'est tellement
impossible à élaborer à la transformer à
comprendre que on serait expose ça c'est
un des effets des traumatismes c'est
vrai pour et c'est là où les où les
enfants les adolescents se
comprendre quoi dans des danseurs de
distorsion où ils vont ça leur fait mal
ils en ont conscience ils peuvent se
culpabiliser mais il serait exposent
éventuellement un doux vraiment cette
notion et là moi je serai pas du tout
psychologique en sur cette question je
dirais mineur ou pas parce que c'est
bien sûr que la sexualité d'un enfant et
d'un adolescent c'est pas pareil et
c'est déjà pas pareil qu'un adulte mais
là la question c'est effectivement c'est
une question plus brute c'est il faut
les protéger de cette de cette
exposition et de cette et de cette
répétition éventuellement du traumatisme
et de la violence et après il y a
d'autres conséquences comme la violence
les normes etc mais il y a déjà le
premier effet sur soi alors il y a pas
seulement les sites internet il y a
aussi la question des des réseaux
sociaux des médias sociaux et c'est ce
que disait Thomas Robert qui est
directeur de l'Observatoire de la
parentalité et de l'éducation numérique
lors de son audition toujours au Sénat
il ciblait Twitter
je vais prendre qu'un seul exemple si on
prend aujourd'hui un réseau social qui
est très dans l'actualité Twitter sur
twitter est-il normal acceptable en 2022
quand quelques clics seulement on tombe
sur des vidéos de pédophilie de
pédopornographie de zoophilie de viol
c'est une question qui reste ouverte
pour ma part je vous doutais de ma
réponse mais je trouve que on oublie
souvent aujourd'hui que certains réseaux
sociaux sont quand même sortent un petit
peu du lot et échappe un peu aux règles
en vigueur en tout cas celle contente de
mettre en place et pour moi Twitter on
est malheureusement la triste
illustration
Justine Atlan demain le pré dans la
République reçoit les acteurs de la tech
comme on dit à l'Elysée est-ce que
est-ce que vous en attendez est-ce que
vous en espérez quelque chose parce que
ça peut être le
l'occasion pour le chef de l'État de
voilà de faire passer un certain nombre
de messages ou de taper du point sur la
table alors oui demain j'ai la chance
d'y être honnête aussi parce qu'on sera
des autres associations d'ONG des
chercheurs enfin il y aura différents
acteurs et des d'autres États
effectivement qui seront présents l'idée
effectivement de mettre tout le monde
autour de la table parce que c'est pas
au niveau français qu'on résoudra les
choses c'est évidemment au niveau
européen international il y a en tout
cas une volonté affichée de demander à
ses acteurs non seulement d'agir mais de
donner des moyens aux initiatives qui à
deux mais effectivement d'associations
ou des tas ou de chercheurs pour trouver
des solutions pratiques la vérification
de l'âge est évidemment le sujet numéro
un qui avait déjà été évoqué l'année
dernière au Parisis forum avec en
présence de kamalari's et effectivement
de sommer un peu les réseaux sociaux de
mettre en place des systèmes de
vérification d'âge parce qu'encore une
fois c'est l'honneur de la guerre c'est
reconnaître en ligne mineur pour leur
offrir dans l'espace numérique les
droits et les devoirs et la protection
auxquels se sont souvent des géants
américains de droits américains
n'est pas moins protecteur que le nôtre
il est même plus puritain à certains
égards notamment vis-à-vis de la
population en train de se poser des
parents ce que disait Mathieu tout à
l'heure qu'est-ce qu'on fait ailleurs
quoi des parents américains cela se la
pose forcément absolument tout le monde
c'est la pause on est bien d'accord non
après effectivement la question encore
une fois c'est que pour l'instant les
réseaux sociaux ont réussi à se
développer comme entreprise tout
simplement en évitant d'avoir à gérer ce
problème là qui est un peu complexe
parce qu'il faut aller chercher les
parents les mettre dans la boucle etc
maintenant c'est vrai qu'ils sont quand
même un peu dans un entonnoir au niveau
mondial et qu'il y a une pression on le
voit bien de la Société des différents
professionnels pour dire maintenant
effectivement ça fait 20 ans qu'on a
privilégié la fluidité de consommation
d'un certain nombre de contenus
l'aisance effectivement voilà des
adultes sur Internet il est peut-être
temps de rééquilibrer un peu parce que
ça a été franchement déséquilibré la
protection de l'enfance elle était
totalement oubliée moi ça fait 17 ans
que je travaille dans ce sujet là dans
la sphère numérique ça fait 17 ans qu'on
a ce genre de débat quand même donc en
2022 je cache pas que je suis épuisé
d'avoir ce type de débat sur des sujets
qui n'ont pas évolué d'un iota depuis
2005 donc live dimanche demain soir
j'espère en tout cas je c'est une des
paroles que j'aurais effectivement de
leur dire maintenant on sait faire on
sait que vous savez faire faites-le
faites-le parce qu'il y a danger parce
qu'il y a danger parce qu'on a créé une
génération la génération Facebook elle a
20 et quelques jours elle arrive dans
une vie d'adulte et c'est dramatique et
elle-même dit mais moi je ne veux pas
que mes enfants voilà pornographie l'âge
à laquelle je l'ai vu moi je ne veux pas
que mes enfants soient sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà avant 13 ans etc voire
même le disent et c'est les parents de
demain donc il va bien falloir faire
quelque chose de forte responsabilité
des parents quand même alors j'ai le
souvenir que gamin mes parents me
laissaient pas regarder n'importe quoi à
la télé est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on laisse
pas les gamins regardez n'importe quoi
je pense qu'on est forcément tous
d'accord là-dessus et sur la sexualité
ça pose d'autres sujets c'est qu'il y a
pas d'alternative finalement d'éducation
à la vie affective et sexuelle que la
pornographie donc déjà ils vont là où il
y a quelque chose qui a rien d'autre et
voilà parce que les parents n'osent pas
soit parce que l'école il y a des
normalement la loi prévoit là aussi je
crois 3
sessions par an d'éducation sexuelle et
on les fait pas on privilégie notre
inconfort notre confort plutôt à ne pas
en parler notre inconfort en parler et
que voilà bon ça c'est un autre débat
qu'on aura peut-être un autre jour mais
mais voilà mais du coup c'est vrai que
les parents bien sûr qu'ils sont ils
sont responsables mais c'est aussi un
argument excusez-moi qu'on utilisait
beaucoup les entreprises numériques pour
dire c'est la faute des parents donc je
suis d'accord qu'il faut responsabiliser
par an mais ça fait 20 ans que les
parents se responsabilisent mais ils
peuvent pas lutter tout seul contre une
offre numérique dans la poche de leur
enfant sous l'oreiller contre laquelle
ils peuvent rien il faut que tout le
monde participe or en face il n'y a rien
qui participe c'est comme comme on
disait les enfants peuvent aller acheter
les cigarettes de l'alcool et finalement
les marchands ils font rien et pareil
ils peuvent pas lutter contre ça vous
voyez à un moment il faut que tout le
monde participe mais là ils sont un peu
seuls les pauvres quand même honnêtes
mes enfants sont grands maintenant mais
voilà ça me rappelle quelques souvenirs
Marie-Rose Moreau c'est vrai que on se
sent souvent démunis quand on est
parents on n'ose pas forcément aborder
la sexualité est-ce que un adolescent
qui a discuté de sexualité avec ses
parents il sera moins attiré par un film
porno ou pas alors déjà la pornographie
c'est pas de la sexualité
de se dire oh on en a pas parlé je sais
pas ce que c'est donc le seul moyen
d'avoir des images de sexe et d'aller
sur un film porno vous voyez ce que je
veux dire effectivement je parlais tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs j'ai pas d'autres
mots que dire l'éducation sentimentale
et sexuelle mais voilà l'éducation aux
relations avec les autres ça c'est une
chose et là effectivement il y a il y a
la place des parents de la famille
élargi de l'école avec cette éducation à
la sexualité qui est qui en fait donc ou
pas assez faite mais c'est ça c'est une
autre question c'est effectivement un
autre débat c'est pas celui de la
pornographie parce que la pornographie
c'est tout autre chose c'est c'est de la
violence c'est de la c'est de la c'est
de la fabrication de quelque chose qui
vient non pas dire c'est comme ça la
sexualité bien elle vient parler d'autre
chose de violence de domination de de
honte de enfin je bref tout tous ces
toutes ces choses très difficiles
d'ailleurs à à regarder à comprendre et
à transformer merci beaucoup merci à
toutes d'avoir participé à tous avec
Matthieu à ceux débat malheureusement je
rappelle le titre de votre livre 50
questions sur les bébés les enfants et
les adolescents au comment devenir des
parents ordinaires aux éditions pensez
sauvage pas des super parents juste des
parents ordinaires prochaine invité
politique sur notre antenne c'est Alexis
Corbières le vice-président du groupe
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
il sera face à Oriane Mancini 8 heures
demain matin bonne soirée